Good afternoon.
Yeah.
Good afternoon, Jonathan. If you're saying something, you have muted.
I think he is struggling to unmute himself.
Oh, yeah, I'm here. Sorry guys. I actually have a conflict of a last minute meeting that popped up today and I thought I was doing that one to be honest with you, so I apologize. Give me a second here. My Outlook's freezing up. Of course, my Outlook's freezing up. Why would it not freeze up?
OK.
Yeah.
Kip.
Let's see.
Did I actually even have the other invite?
I may actually have to, why is this not opening?
Not an issue. We understand, you know, things do come up and depending upon the urgency, criticality, please do let us know if some other day time would be suitable to you for your convenience and I'll match with my calendar.
Yeah, give me one second. I'm trying to get confirm this real quick.
Sure, take your time.
Yeah, let me see real quick. Let's get this one rescheduled if possible, because this was a last minute meeting that popped up for one of our clients. It's going through a transition here.
Hmm?
Yeah.
I just realized I didn't have the invite that they said they sent.
Uh, do do do, let me get my calendar in order here for the week.
Would you like this to be this week itself till Friday or maybe next week?
Let me look, I'm trying to look and see right now.
Okay, Calendar.
I'll tell you what, I can probably just see these here on my phone at this point.
Could we look at, um...
At Friday.
A day after tomorrow.
Yes, this Friday.
Yeah, what time?
Um...
We could do it around the same time. Looks good.
Allow me just one quick minute, please. Just a moment.
If you have availability.
Yep.
Sir, I'm available. Would you be?
Fine with me.
Yeah, Jonathan, that works for both of us. I mean, three of us.
Okay.
That sounds perfect. Sorry for that last minute mix up there.
No problem at all.
No, I completely understand this. And yeah, well, thank you. We'll see you soon. And just one thing, if you, I probably did send the CSAT, I mean, feedback for Victor last month, I mean, redirected to you. Previously, it was going to Kris.
Yep.
So please do check your email. It must be from email that is monthly feedback for Victor. Okay, so if you receive that, so if you get a chance, please fill that up. I would appreciate that. Thank you.
Okay.
Thank you, Jonathan. Have a good day.
Sounds good.
All right, thank you very much. We'll connect again. Thank you. Looking forward to connecting again. Bye-bye.
Appreciate it. Thank you.
Take care, bye bye.
Yep, bye.